Attended
about a month ago,
a meeting in Japan in Kyoto organized by
a remarkable individual named a Koji Omi
who was among other things or finance
minister of Japan for awhile and I only
saw one,
has been holding this annual conference
on science,
technology and society and he calls it
light and shadow,
a very Japanese way of saying science
can shed light to extraordinary positive
things that it also has a dark side.
It creates shadows.
This is true of anything economic power,
military power and scientific power have
a bright side.
They have a dark side.
We must be very aware of that.
I'm a great believer that
we should have full freedom as
conceivable for the human mind to
explore nature and understand.
However,
we have to be aware of the consequences
of some of the kinds of knowledge that
we are beginning to develop and I
suspect that over this coming decade or
so,
that we're going to face a lot of very
deeply ethical questions.
As life science becomes more and more
the basis of technology and action.
We should never be afraid of learning of
discovery,
but we need to be cautious as we move
into new technological areas because
they move so fast,
you know,
in the old days,
you could generally develop technology.
It took a lifetime,
uh,
you know,
for the automobile to reach 25 percent
of the public,
whereas the worldwide web did it and
seven and a half years.
So this,
this pace
doesn't always give us the time to think
through before we moved.
And we saw that in genetically modified
foods which created a cultural figure in
Europe that the people who were doing
the original marketing really hadn't
stepped back and thought through.
So the two areas that I think we're
going to have to think deeply about are
certainly,
uh,
the whole world that's beginning to
evolve of synthetic biology and the
increasing genetic knowledge.
We're going to have a very selves and
others.
What really is going to constitute
wisdom?
How are we going to decide what one
wants to know?
Uh,
how do we start thinking about things
when we begin creating life forms which
were doing,
you know,
you walk up and down the halls of a
place like mit,
hear the kids talking about biohacking.
That means,
you know,
we're taking organisms,
we're taking the stuff of life and we're
mixing it up and playing around.
We're not creating monsters when we're
doing things at a molecular level that
we have to think through what's going to
happen.
The whole field of genetic counseling,
what do you want to know?
Should you know,
should you know that you've got an very
high probability of having Alzheimer's,
uh,
later on.
So I think most of the areas we have to
think most deeply about are going to be
driven by the infusion of life science
into things that directly affect us into
medicine,
into the production and materials and so
forth.
At the same time,
I don't want to slow that because I
believe within,
it belies a lot of the resolution of
environmental problems and so forth
because we learned from nature to design
and grow as opposed to physically
manufacture materials.
We can do it generally with a lot less
energy,
with more uses of natural materials and
so forth,
but we do have to think that through a
more understandable example because
we're in some ways further down the path
is people will have some legitimate
concerns about nanotechnology and it's a
complicated area because a nano just
really refers to building things out of
extremely small molecules and particles
and we've been doing this forever on one
hand,
but on the other hand,
we're starting to,
uh,
take metals and various materials and
put them in this very small form that
can enter directly into cells,
can be breathed in,
in different ways.
Chances are 99 percent of it is not
going to be dangerous,
but we have to be willing to kind of
make the investments as we go along to
engage bright people who by the way
cannot all be professional scientists
and engineers.
We need lay people and thinkers engaged
and just think airway through some of
these issues.
At the same time,
you know,
I believe in boldness and I believe in
taking risks.
It's just that we don't want to take
risks on scales and with people who
don't know they're taking risk and so
forth.
We just need deeper thought and these
newer areas because they're moving so
rapidly and I think we're going to face
some really tough ethical decisions in
these areas and they're not gonna all be
easily resolved and going back to
something you asked about earlier,
it can't just be science and
engineering.
You know it.
We live in a democracy.
We have political processes for making
decisions.
We just want those decisions to be truly
well informed and questions shaped in
ways that really make sense and are
appropriate.